[Music]
hello hello are we live how profession
are bumper in and everything oh hell
yeah
heck yes that's what I'm talking about
look out now that's what I'm talking
about
whoo all right guys were experimenting
with these mics so if you can just go to
the chat and tell us if you can hear us
on the mics because this is our first
time we've ever tried using a microphone
like this hell yeah
John we got zero eyes on us at the movie
right now we're about to get so many
more eyes let's get one more yeah let's
get our tweets and info out there let's
take this time to plug ourselves oh we
got some people coming in what's up guys
how to low hello hello Adrian Carter
Jorge Kevin Yoda
Jorge again Brandon you guys can hear us
you guys can hear us this is good news
can you hear this is great news for
everyone involved today
all right so how many people we got on
the chat at the moment right now we have
44 as according to this icon on our
window as far as I'm concerned that's
all I care about
mmm-hmm so how we're gonna do this and
in case anyone starts coming in and
talking I wanted to tell you that we are
gonna first talk about bad boys 3 and
then we're gonna open up the forum here
guys help us catch up on movie news a
little bit behind I keep hearing I keep
seeing like titles for things I'm not
hearing enough details on them but last
night we saw bad boys 3 and it was an
experience and so I want to talk with
you guys about it right now
first they who here in the chat has seen
bad boys for life some people have just
gone to go see I leave your comments
down below tell us what you think about
them greetings to Wakanda all right John
kick us off what did you think of bad
boys for life you know I was pleasantly
surprised by bad boys for life I mean
you know
I went in basically expecting you know
just like another rehash of bad boys but
more stale I guess if I'm being honest
and I got something that was really fun
and more a little less abrasive than the
previous one so yeah I quite enjoyed
myself I don't think it's like perfect
there are some things that could drag
less and there are some things that
could be tighter but uh overall I
thought it was a blast
yeah I actually had a really great time
with this movie the first half I thought
had uh I guess what surprised me about
this film was just so many graphics on
screen it was surprising about this film
was just how how much more weight there
was to it they they flushed out the
characters more especially than Mike
Lowrey character I mean it's funny
because there was some like weird
parallels I drew with rush hour 3 out of
any franchise because there was rush
hour 1 & 2 which had Jackie Chan his
top-billed actor in there and then rush
hour 3 came out and it was Chris Tucker
who was top-billed actor in that movie
and then in this film it was it's like
the first two bad boys movies it's
Martin Lawrence as top-billed and then
Will Smith the second build and and
Martin Lawrence has apparently been in a
retirement or something like that and
then they come out with this I'm like
okay just make sense Will Smith the main
star and then as the credits are rolling
in the beginning you see Will Smith
produce this movie come to find out this
movie is mainly a Will Smith movie oh
yeah and and oh my god Martin and Marcus
are kissed heavily a supporting
character here but funny enough while
Will Smith it obviously worked with the
writers be like a 101 Mike to be much
more fleshed out more what like my the
the note that John and I were making fun
of while we were actually watching this
movie is I'm all for making sequels and
stuff especially to come back like this
to make it more special to make it more
personal mi3 did that this movie does it
usually sequels good ones at least
usually attempt to make their movies
more personal and they make this one a
lot more personal sometimes too much
things that happen especially in the
finale of this film but like the last
half hour some twist there's like
surprisingly some twists and turns and
reveals that happen then I was like we
didn't eat that roll with it
we didn't need it there there there's
some times stretching a little too far
to make it that much more personal there
is a heavy injection of melodrama which
the movie to its credit is self-aware of
but yeah it does Teeter on the edge of
being kind of like a fate of the furious
so hurts like this is this yeah you know
and I think they they ultimately wind up
on the right side of that line but yeah
it is a little bit like the character
drama now well there's there's some
things that I kind of thought of but
we're trying to we're parallel two men
in black 3 which was you know another
movie that the part three took a long
time to come out Tommy Lee Jones was the
main star of that one originally Will
Smith becomes the main star of MIB three
and then agent K is kind of gone for
yeah a bit and before he's you know
remade the Agent K characters back with
Will Smith and that's when the movie
really shines and it's kind of a similar
thing that happens with that without
spoiling anything that's why I think
that like in the first and like the
first half of act 2 it's not really Will
Smith and Martin Lawrence it's mainly
Will Smith being you know dramatic Will
Smith yeah and then when Martin Lawrence
and Will Smith are backed and their
chemistry is really on screen on display
the movie really shines because Martin
Lawrence is hysterical in this film he
hasn't lost a beat in terms of being a
comedic performer he isn't he is he
really does shine a hell of a lot here
and he embraces the supporting role and
I was really happy that he did and it
seemed like he was aware like yeah I've
been gone Will Smith is a freaking
superstar
yeah I'll embrace the supporting role
and he he nails it and their chemistry
is just undeniably amazing in this he is
so good like even when some of the
writing isn't as funny or as clever as
it thinks it is their chemistry does so
much for everything in the movie pretty
much yeah
and they're super fun to watch together
and what's also funny too is that
there's the the in the trailers they
were teasing that they're gonna have
like these other cast members Vanessa
Hudgens being one of them and she's like
third building this room you think yeah
yeah and of the other team she arguably
has the least focus sure but she's the
most famous of them notables so we're
gonna be live for a while guys don't
work so yeah when but usually in these
kind of sequels those other new members
you're like who cares about them I don't
care about them they ended up being
really great there's a couple of players
in that new team that really do they
don't steal the show they don't become
the main characters but they're a really
good like they're they're great addition
this movie has a very shining supporting
cast like across the board and yeah
especially those characters can often be
the sort of like I can see what you're
doing you want to continue this past the
point that the stars can but yeah like
even the way that they grew into the
story really justified it every
character had a personality and they
even bothered to give them little arcs
here and there so like they did work on
the script that you arguably wouldn't
have to and everybody on the team that
they're working with gets a chance to
shine - yeah and this movie has a lot
more you'd like you drew parallels to
fast and furious and yeah there is that
that thing of like there's a lot of
family vibes in here yeah on both sides
with the villains and the good guys a
lot of a lot of family stuff immature
bad boy yeah a lot of heart and okay so
I mean Michael Bay did not return for
this one so how's the directing with it
I think it's a lot I don't want to say
restrained but it's not as by comparison
that is fantastic I would say like cuz
like those especially bad boys to which
I know a lot of people love it's nonstop
loud you know in oh yeah it's just a
whole lot of bombastic energy for two
and a half straight hours this movie
actually takes time to slow down this
movie takes time to have some like real
scenes and I will say with the comedy
that because even though we were talking
about how this movie goes for a lot more
weight at times and gravitas with the
comedy would surprise me like there are
scenes that are obviously from beginning
and
to be funny there there's a lot of
surprising comedy in here though
where though they'll be like a really
serious moment they'll be very serious
and then suddenly there'll be a joke
that you just don't see coming and it
doesn't feel left field it doesn't feel
like it's undercutting the scene it's
within character and it doesn't do that
thing that people complain about with
certain Marvel movies or even the DC
inspired by Marvel movies where the joke
undercuts the scene or takes the tension
out like they they managed to blend
their comedy in really well which is
important for bad boys yeah you've got
two guys with insane comedic chops at
the forefront and yeah I thought the the
two guys who directed this brought a lot
of style that's familiar they clearly
referenced Michael Bay's sort of check
this out like everything is the money
shot style but they tamed it enough to
where it's not edited to [ __ ] and and
you can actually tell what's going on
most of the time it has better like
spatial geography I feel like I know
some people are bringing up a certain
cameo in the chat and then if you're
yeah we did we of course we noticed it
we even noticed that a shot yeah very
much in tribute to it very much and and
I I don't know what the audience
reception is - if they prefer this Oh I
personally I I thought this might have
been the best one there I think it's the
best like I could see why if you love
bad boys too significantly more I can
see that for me I thought this was the
the better composed one real purple -
really purple
it took some notes off John wick and
movies like that yeah I mean they've
always had garish lighting and in these
movies Michael Bay likes garish lighting
but yeah a lot of purple a lot of Blues
in this one and and yeah just the the
overall it's like the cuddly astad boys
in a way because the characters are
growing like even though they do cause a
lot of destruction still and they are
still got the attitude it's not as
wanton and it's not as like
mean-spirited I don't know like yeah
it's like they are confronting their age
in ways even though they're doing the
action still and I thought that it's
kind of like what I appreciate about
every Evil Dead movie not that these are
anyway similar but you know
ash has changed a little bit each time
it's not like a cartoon where just you
reset every time and see I appreciated
that they took their age took advantage
of that you know there there are things
in here though
there there are things that happen in
this movie that I could only describe as
this reminds me a lot of Gemini man but
I just can't flash in a Gemini man like
this movies not perfect I think in the
first half of act 2 it kind of drew we
really kind of dragged for me a little
bit but at the same time I got to say
this I got point this out of why I think
I might have dragged okay I was saying
next to some guy I vape I I'm a vapor or
I quit cigarettes but I vape there was
some fire every 5 to 10 minutes who is
smoking his jewel and I've never dealt
with a guy who's pissing me off so much
who's sitting right next to me and I I'm
not comfortable with confrontation in
general with strangers
yeah but the first half of that movie
every 5-10 minutes he was to eventually
says eventually told him you have to
stop making your puncture road I told
him he was being rude he did stop but it
was half of my attention was focused on
him so I don't know if that's why
sometimes I thought it was kind of
dragging for me but so there were parts
of the first half of back to that
thought dragged a little bit but there
are things that they do were like some
things I was saying with reveals or
whatever I was like this really seems
like gemini man territory I know Will
Smith produced both was this his note it
was yeah one the Will Smith's thing to
include in the script and I've been
certain visual and and just set aspects
kind of harken to that movie I found
myself thinking of a couple movies
during this and and that was certainly
one of them yeah but I think Gemini man
should have come out this month and bad
boys three should have come out in
October yeah I came out right Gemini man
bad boys for you to come out then
because this movie is significantly
better
almost every fashion yeah cuz Gemini man
you know as like the cool act look great
action it's but the plot is like
boilerplate nineties yeah alright guys
well yeah to sum it up go watch bad boys
for life you like the
bad boys movies go check it out but yeah
I wanted to talk about that and now we
can go into the chat a little bit and
see what's going on yeah can you guys
still hear us we're gonna start going
through some of your questions Oh super
jet a super chat let's give a shout out
or hey the only one the only one let's
thank you buddy graphic down thank you
buddy
really appreciate it we're big fans of
you whoo all right John pick a question
out of here all righty let's find a
question how would we rank it against
the previous bad boys Oh like I said I
would rank this one thank you John for
the question I would rank this one
probably at yeah number one I would
ranked him I would write them in
descending order 3 2 1
yeah it would be my order from best to
not as great that's my personal ranking
maybe 3 1 2 just to throw a wrench sure
in there for you oh man
let's see Will's ears Martin's belly
amen there was some ear jokes there was
some ear jokes there's a lot of
questions about which bad boys people
from England hear what's up people from
England people from Nigeria hello to
Nigeria we've got a lot of let's go up
thoughts on Quentin Tarantino making a
bounty law TV show now that's the kind
of movie news were looking for Thank You
Tyler there you go
have you heard about this news I have
not this is the news to me
all right I actually did hear about this
one so Quentin Tarantino said that he he
has I think he said that he has like
five scripts written for bounty law like
five half-hour episodes and he wants to
actually bring them to life he wants to
make them and if anyone follows
Tarantino I mean you know that he's the
kind of guy who has all kinds of ideas
and says he wants to make this movie
Vega brothers Kill Bill three Star Trek
four but a lot of these never end up
happening they never end up going
anywhere but he seems to really be in
love and Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
that whole world and the fact that he
said he has them written already makes
the world of difference I
he said he wrote them in preparation to
kind of understand a little bit more of
the Rick Dalton character so this
wouldn't be about Rick Dalton yeah this
wouldn't be about you know here in the
show it would be episodes of the show I
feel like they'll be really I think it'd
be great too if he got to Caprio and
there I feel like it'd be really awesome
if he was able to to get like certain
moments where you could kind of tell is
that Brad Pitt being a stunt double for
DiCaprio right I think that'd be neat I
think you get like they had cameos
they're like Michael Madsen
I remember once upon a time in Hollywood
he was part of the show I think you get
a lot of big-name actors to make cameos
and appearances in here I think DiCaprio
might even be on board for it I think
that would be really cool I would love
love for that to happen yeah man I think
that would be I love like shows within
the shows that actually get to be real
and you know there aren't that many of
them but if that seems like the most
interesting version of that to me too
because you know that Tarantino a has
probably seen every show that that would
be in reference to so you know it's
gonna have that encyclopedic you know
old Hollywood movie knowledge and I feel
like he would actually put something
into it cuz I feel like a lot of
spin-offs you know kind of pale a little
bit or they just don't have um that the
you know thing they're coming out of
does but I feel like Tarantino would
take that pretty seriously yeah he would
put his all into that I see people talk
asking about the thoughts on the M&M
album if you follow me on Instagram I
have the Greg Alba over there I was at
the worked out today and I listened to
pretty much I think I'm like one song
away from finishing the album and we and
we shot a music video reaction for
patreon to the to the darkness song that
went up just yesterday it's funny has
songs so I got like seven million views
in less than 24 hours on YouTube not
trending on YouTube but then you see the
content that's in there and it makes
sense why I love the album I really did
I I think it's I personally preferred
over the Kamikaze album which I thought
was a really good album wasn't one of my
favorites I think this is his best album
pers this knob in my opinion I think
it's my favorite album of his since
recover
I think it's a just a truly wonderful
album and that song darkness is great we
did a reaction for it on patreon well
we're planning on what we're thinking of
doing is tomorrow putting up the review
for it because normally to do a reaction
on YouTube for these kind of songs you
have to do the thing that'll like people
like Sean C or Fontana or any other
music leader actors do is they they
watch us this song and they pause it and
they talk about the lyrics yeah or just
more speed through the part where
they're listening and they can just get
to the review afterward and I want to
say I didn't want to do that just for my
own personal experience because I wanted
to absorb the whole music video in one
sitting and so what we'll probably do is
have like a Vimeo link for our music
video reaction but then have our review
up on YouTube I'll probably still be
titled reaction so everyone knows but
yeah that's that'll be going up tomorrow
but what do you guys think of the album
have you guys heard the songs love to
know what you guys think of them ooh
here's an interesting one about the
movie I would imagine why is no one
talking about how this looks and feels
like a love letter to vintage John Woo
movies I wouldn't have pulled that
reference but oh you mean for like bad
boys for life yeah I don't know why is
no one to wear the doves answer it or
the doves I don't know why no one's
talking I think it's because John Woo is
not well within the zeitgeist at the
moment who was the last American John
Woo movie or a movie that made a splash
over here hey Lisa thanks for watching
all the way at midnight in your area
hell alot to me
how's your puzzle guy do you guys ever
watch indie movies yes they just don't
get any views when we review them what
the hell is an indie movie guys my
favorite movie of the decade if you
watched my reaction to watch mojo's
video of top 10 best movies of the
decade
I'd say they're my favorite movie of the
decade is is Ryan Gosling Nicolas when
the reference drive which is an indie
film so yeah I do like indie films watch
parasite oh gotta say a last time I did
a live stream I was talking about how
I'm on my way to go watch 19:17 mmm and
holy [ __ ] you guys got to go watch that
movie
we watch I watched it on an IMAX at
Universal CityWalk where there's a real
IMAX 3 and they clearly shot it with
special IMAX cameras not that nothing to
the degree that Noland uses it for but
the ones that like Michael Bay use for
transformers what it takes up most of
the screen not the whole thing but it
was a one hell of an immersive
experience I totally get why people are
raving about this movie and I don't know
if it's my favorite movie of the year
but it's certainly one of the best
movies of 2019 undoubtably and a
remarkable achievement in every way and
and the thing I was telling people like
two things that no one's talking about
the thing that I want to like add on to
this two things that people aren't
talking about the editing with that film
because supposed to look like one take
people don't notice the editing but they
didn't shoot that in one shot you know
you gotta you gotta give credit to that
the editing and also uh what's the lead
actors named George McKay George McKay
George McKay the main actor in that film
is incredible
if we're gonna praise the [ __ ] out of
DiCaprio for going through physical
performance in the revenant no dude what
this guy does here in the level that's
not easy memorization that's not easy
choreography and there's a lot of
physicality with that role but there's
also a lot of emotional layers
throughout that entire if it goes on a
whole arc primarily through body
language and he is phenomenal and
no-one's raving about him like I hear no
one talking about him he is incredible
in that film really yeah he gives like
the super physical but also super
vulnerable performance and there's so
much subtlety in what he's giving off in
his face and his mannerisms and yet yeah
I'm I feel like though the one shot
thing is just overshadowing all the talk
and then when you go see it you're like
it's so much more than that
apparently the directors of bad boys for
life are directing the Beverly Hills Cop
on Netflix huh ways the Beverly Hills
Cop thing supposed to be a movie urchin
Oh thoughts on crisis on Infinite Earths
Thank You Mimi for that well I gotta say
I don't know who has or hasn't seen I
thought it was fun
I thought was a lot of fun this stuff
they did with Oliver Queen
I'm not the biggest fan of I feel like a
lot of people really liked and I'm
probably in the minority on it it was
alright but but they they jam-packed it
with so many more cameos and I realized
there was like I I would sometimes bring
up the random birds of prey show of the
hunters character that no one seems to
remember her when she popped up I'm like
holy [ __ ] they brought her back and then
crossing over like the quick montages
that people like Doom Patrol Titans all
these other shows is great but of course
the thing I mean maybe you even heard
about the same girl watch the show but
Ezra Miller is the flash oh yeah
appearing in the fourth episode of
Christ on Infinite Earths that was
pretty cool even though I I got spoiled
for me because the second it came out
everyone was posting about it on social
media got spoiled for me I thought it
was that was a lot of fun man and it was
cool to see like hey he's he is
committed to this and apparently it was
Warner Brothers idea to do that and
what's really cool about the outcome of
what they don't crisis on Infinite
Earths is they've managed to connect
everything because it's been a big
stipulation with what the DC shows is
that they're they're separate they're
different than the movies are not
connected and now they have successfully
managed to open it up the portals
literally here they they're not now all
the shows and the movies the whole world
of DC is now I think even cry don't know
about crap I don't watch Krypton but
yeah but I think it's all connected now
right that must be what it is it's a
goal that's the Cinematic Universe we we
deserve right now let's see we got
another question thanks Kim Wexler for
that question earlier by the way LA who
Sotomayor hey y'all quick question what
do you think about Ricky Gervais is
comments in the last Golden Globes we
were just talking about this we were
actually shooting a video about various
Ricky Gervais Golden Globe comments you
know I we were I think we both have an
appreciation from what Ricky Gervais
does it's it's equal parts gut-busting
and cringy just because you know that
he's making people in the room
uncomfortable he's kind of row
ding the the very thing we're here to do
but I thought especially in his opening
monologue some of those points were
incisive I mean I don't especially mind
when celebrities use that moment to
speak on a cause they like but that I'll
that sort of checked their of like
remember that a lot of you guys work for
these big corporations that have really
poor business practices so like you know
you're not necessarily the authority
when there are more areas that you could
be tightening up or whatever but there
were so many I just loved how like is
his repeated mantra I don't care that's
my last time I don't care why is Kim
Wexler saying it's a waste of time to
argue about the artistic merits of pop
films um because I mean whoa I just to
go hand raisi in this chat right now I
guess it depends on where you're arguing
from and and what I mean like I don't
think there's no artistic merit to pop
filmmaking but I would say that there's
on average probably a lot more to
dissect with not pop filmmaking because
like they're not engineered so much to
please everyone indie films hey Jon you
are perfect casting for the passions of
Jesus Christ to the passions of Jesus
Christ yeah yeah yeah because it's the
sequel you got a more even more passion
passions Oh Maria Hammond thank you so
much bye Maria was saying thank you so
much for congratulating me on jus
actually John has joined the faction on
the Schmo down as well part of it and
yeah I got gypped on my award I was
pissed I should have pulled a Roca and
been a little baby about it haha
usually gotten sort of had my ego ruined
the night you should have just gotten
really good friend help them out with
this channel recently about a bit hey
Michael rut Michael Roy bow thank you so
much yeah hey guys my name is Michael
and I just turned 21 like a few days ago
me and my girl just had her kid wait
okay and I am the dad now so so are you
know so you're not the biological father
so usually funnier if you are the
biological father and you're like but
that's your kid in case I want out of
this any time soon
just in case just in case I just want to
lay down some ground one out of this
I will interact with a child I will give
it food and necessities but I don't
claim ownership of the child
in fact I'll just call him the child or
her the child or they of the child man
what a crazy new year for you to have it
turned 21 and then you're not able to
usually people turn 21 it's time to go
to a strip club and party but you had a
kid instead whoo good for you man hey
there gonna be a responsible adult Inger
Leon its adult had some mad respect for
you congratulations to you and your lady
happy 21st birthday by the way you've
earned the right intent thank you for
your super jet that's really kind of you
it should probably save your money for
the kid but but thank you appreciate no
no no she's got to do this if I can
Wechsler appreciate him I hope you're
having a good night today whatever
oh.why thoughts on national treasure
three I'm excited we got our we got to
protect the treasure big love for
national treasure
you know mmm I have no idea how that
happened did national treasure to do
well I've heard their fun I've heard
they're disposable fun yeah but I don't
know anybody who especially loves
national treasure but you can't keep a
good cage down you know he's he's having
a renaissance again in the indie scene
I'm surprised I haven't heard a lot of
people at least from my glancing at the
chat I haven't seen people talking about
a taiko YTD possibly directing and that
seems to be the main so I'm like okay
there's probably gonna be a lot of
people asking about this and I probably
have a lot of regret for not looking up
anything about hmm but John what do you
think of tyka white eighty what I used
to come T ki watts it's a member's name
what do you think about him directing a
Star Wars flick umm I think two things
one I think that's an exciting prospect
because he
is a multi-faceted and very thoughtful
filmmaker but that said I think Rian
Johnson is too and we all saw what
happened in the public spirit Lee as
much as I enjoyed that movie I don't
really know because I'm weary of Star
Wars movies now in general like the new
phase has only produced a couple we can
all agree are pretty enjoyable or most
of us agree are pretty enjoyable so
while I have no doubt that he can do it
and obviously like his Mandalorian
finale episode is a great audition I
feel like it's ultimately going to come
down to whatever the Disney heads have
because I don't know I mean it seems
like if they learn from this experience
they'll need to go into their next Star
Wars films with a plan of some kind or
at least a willingness to take what was
before and work with it so I don't know
I'm excited in general for him and for
his Sensibility perhaps broadening out
Star Wars but I would really need to
know what the project is I guess I hope
that now that the Skywalker SOG has done
they will really branch out the movies
and maybe he can help with that
whoa Mohammed Seth MacFarlane Lena Fox
the NBC Peacock is that true shots fire
I didn't know anything about that
that's pretty nuts to me I didn't know
that means death McFarland's made his
home a fox he became the animation
domination and then the Star Trek I used
to know we had we got buttons for you
went to the panel the Orville
Redenbacher yeah I mean that's kind of I
I'm not excited for anything NBC has
coming out peacock neck were things a
terrible was the peacock screaming
someone that peacock in there's a
terrible title they're [ __ ] seven
selves up for disaster to be fun
thinking with that but sure why not
um actually what surprised me was was
hearing about was a Disney is getting
rid of the the Fox title oh what a
caller like Searchlight Pictures or
something like that
aha I forget what it's not the sole
survivor they're not gonna use the Fox
brand anymore
oh man which I'm kind of impartial too
cuz I don't do any no no the people have
fun I don't know but in a lot of ways I
can see how people will be really upset
about that how that is an insult to
legacy especially after you inherit
something you just get rid of the name
yeah and not in here but buy it that's
that's pretty messed up that's pretty
messed up well yeah and I mean the
details are foggy on me now because I
watched it so many years ago but Fox you
know like the namesake of the studio I
saw this documentary called Murnau
burrows Iggy and Fox about like early
Hollywood and innovation and Fox was one
of the younger studios but they did a
lot especially the head of fight like he
was really into innovation within cinema
and pushed a lot of things forward so it
does bum me out a little bit to see the
Fox name go away because of just its
place in movie history more than
anything but a girl I'm glad for
Searchlight though because arguably
that's the strongest and my favorite
wing of Fox
so who thought Doolittle would be a good
movie yeah especially when there's a
dragon in it like who I have people are
talking about Doolittle in the chat who
thought that would be a good film like
it did I I mean when we do these trailer
reactions I try to give the benefit of
the doubt I don't like to just go
sometimes I look it's a trailer I I get
it it's just a trailer it doesn't look
very good for whatever but seriously who
watched it and was like this is gonna be
something special
you know I was actually what surprising
me from the feedback I'm hearing is the
negative talk about Robert Downey jr.
performance specifically and that bums
me out because I literally just watched
our listen to the if you guys haven't
heard the Joe Rogan interview with him
Robert Downey jr. it's great my favorite
interview Robert Downey jr. ever he does
not walk out on him it's awesome and him
and Robert Downey jr. went back and
forth so long talking about why he did
Doolittle and it was the first time I
was like
I think I might go watch Dolittle and
then you hear everything I'm like that's
everything I was worried about but
everyone's kind of clowning on his
performance
already January expected to be one of
the biggest flops of the year yeah it's
weird because of all there
you know revitalizing and revamping I
was like who is this one out of all of
them for like who nowadays is champing
at the bit to revitalize dr. Dolittle
and I mean you know Eddie Murphy got a
couple movies out of it and turned it
into a vehicle but this almost seems
like I was really reminded of Sherlock
Holmes but just like with a different
setting like I'm a little afraid that
this character might become like what
Jack Sparrow is to Johnny Depp where
it's like you know this is a Robert
Downey jr. paycheque movie you know he
seemed like he was very passionate like
everything I've heard he's he seems very
sincere doesn't sound like you can tell
when someone say marketing [ __ ] and when
someone sounds sincere any he see a
common thing I've heard too
is that the movie did not seem like ill
intention at all that it seemed like
they were always thought they were going
for the most sincere best thing they
could possibly do I know I'm speaking
only about you know other people's
opinions yeah to me I'm just like this
is he I'd be surprised if I watched it
and I was like wow I disagree with
everyone because this sounds almost
exactly like what I what I expected it
to be Britney Lange thank you so much
yeah I appreciate that Britney one of
our most loyal subscribers don't know
why you're not showing up in that I can
put on screen but thank you so much
thank you Kim she says that I looked
just enough like kylo Ren that she'd
have me for one night I'll take discount
kylo Ren you can take discount Jesus and
I'll take to somebody somebody said I
look like the Winter Soldier if he
didn't get a metal arm and didn't get
buff which is a wonderfully backhanded
compliment those are the best you look
like famous character or celebrity is
when it's followed way more normal and
like a fatter yeah you look like a
scrawny Winter Soldier things like that
what did you think of Joaquin's Golden
Globes speech best best
that was a big catapult for me it wasn't
aware the Golden Globes was going
plant-based that night and for all the
statues were made of plants all the
statues and for the longest time I've
been thinking about like try that thing
of like if you don't eat meat for once a
week you save this many animals in yada
yada yada
so my girlfriend's a vegetarian I've
thought about being vegetarian and and
all this things vironment never going on
the fires in Australia and there was
something about his speech that made me
go I think I should just finally do it
you know I started smoking cigarettes
years ago because of Ryan Gosling so
maybe I can do something good because of
walking just make sure all your favorite
celebrities are vocal about good cause
yeah I mean like I I loved his speech
but when he was talking about the
environment it that did click so I'm not
vegetarian but I've made it a commitment
to at least once a week not eat meat but
funny enough for 17 16 17 days in into
January and correct looks like a Jewish
amount of days into into January and I
haven't eaten meat for nine or ten days
some something like that so I'm already
ahead of the 52 days walking yeah
walking would be proud but I just feel
better not eating actually generally I
feel better not Amy I have digestion
issues major ones take from that what
you will
well yeah I I'm feeling good about that
so walking Phoenix thank you for being
the linchpin this whole thing well I
like I like to the he was he said the
one thing in the room like there there
is a prestige to winning these awards
but I like that he led with like you
know it doesn't really matter it's just
advertising for the movies and I
appreciated how he summed it up because
it did seem to kind of bring everything
back to earth for a second for how
decadent and how sloshed that night gets
I thought he weirdly as loose as he can
be in as sort of unpredictable I thought
yeah he he actually brought the room
together in a nice way Jorge the only
one thank you again
anyone thank you thank you and maybe our
friend who just had a kid should uh hmm
should open up a super share - yeah live
stream like your universe background
that's the BTS world right there yes
any thoughts on Black Widow yeah I got
plenty of thoughts did to reactions for
it I'm looking forward to it yeah I feel
like the hype for Marvel phase four has
been um you know if like you're a Marvel
fan you're probably I feel like people
generally are looking forward to it but
they're not sure what to be excited for
it's different than endgame you're like
I don't know what's gonna go on in this
movie but I'm excited for it I know the
significance and the stakes phase four
is gonna be very different the fact that
they're kicking this off and then I this
that's the main thought I have on block
row that I feel like I can contribute is
people you know people have been saying
like they feel like this still might be
in unnecessary film it's a little too
late even though the film looks really
cool is it really necessary to do this
one I feel like there's gonna be
something in that movie that gets us
really excited for the continuation of
phase four there's something that are
not showing us in those trailers which
that's great they're not showing us but
I think there's gonna be things would be
like whoa wasn't expecting to be to this
like when we see those early reactions
on Twitter don't want to spoil anything
but seriously stick stick around for
this you know who because those things
to get excited for for phase four to
come and I feel like that's like I'm
excited just to see the story and it of
itself the style the execution dance
ombo especially figure now who really is
under the taskmaster mask sure but I
think in terms of exciting us for phase
4 I think there's gonna be something
there that we just have no idea exactly
what it's gonna be yet well yeah and
especially the way that they released
that tease and then also put out the
special look and both of them kind of
borrow from the same sequences for the
most part they don't like the special
look doesn't give you much that's
remarkably different from what we saw in
that first trailer so it seems as though
they may be doing and I kind of like
that it seems like this is their new
trailer formula like with endgame and
then Spiderman far from home obviously
those movies had bigger things to hide
but I feel like it's a smart way to do
it toll from a few scenes get us excited
for the style and then surprise
during the movie yeah and we got a
couple jumping off that birds-of-prey
questions what did we think of the
recent trailer and the rumors that it
may be the bloodiest DC film yet and
lives up to the r rating I really hope
that's true man yeah I really hope
that's true because it seems like the
there were like there are people who
seem like really excited for it and
there are people who seem kind of
lukewarm about it I don't know any
people who are like it looks terrible I
think that was a saga I was having like
a kind of an in-depth conversation with
someone about the other day I feel like
it's gonna be something pretty cool I
think is gonna be something more special
than we realize it will be if it is this
hard our film though that people are
talking about we should get a red band
trailer yeah they should really
demonstrate that this is good I think
that would excite a lot of people yeah I
think you really got to put that on
display because not even the last
trailer I think had a rating on it yet
and I think we should get a red band
trailer for for that I would excite
people especially in this time that we
live in
Oh Luis Luis Loulou you can love you
guys
oh it's a pleasure watching your video
like your icon buddy I like your Lulu
glass not true is that supposed to be in
reference to Metallica and Lou Reed's
Lulu their most beloved album
respectively it actually kind of looks
like Elliott from etc' yeah the wild
berries that was what I thought at first
actually we've covered this Christian
thank you Christian a little but I
didn't talk about it what are your
thoughts on your boy tyka now it's my
turn
jump I only answer if it's a super shot
about psycho that's why I didn't say
anything
CD chats hey Dhanraj is here well
Christian um I I think I think it's a
great idea because the he directed the
final episode of the mandalorian and did
he
that was him right and I remember
watching that episode and not pick I
didn't know who directed that episode
and then it was like halfway through and
I think you know our reaction I say it
I've liked it Tyko YTD do this
because there cuz the banter at the top
yeah then there's sort of being earmarks
of it that's started reminding me of Ty
Cobb YTD but after seeing what he did
yeah of course there's thor ragnarok the
great hilarious cosmic awesome action
movie they did in MCU which was one of
their staple films and then of course
you know Joe Joe rabbit is another
amazing film he liked his other work
with fantasy as well that he's done I
mean even what we do in the shadows is
technically under the fantasy umbrella
I think Tiger YTD could bring and I'm
honestly I feel like the whole team
should do something Dave Filoni Jon
Favreau and Tyco white if you had like a
story in script by Tyco YTD and Dave
Filoni directed by Tyco YTD produced by
Jon Favreau like I think that'd be
something pretty sweet I mean I'd like
the whole team coming together for that
I would really dig that a lot not that I
am a champion of just like give one
person everything but I you know
especially right now it seems like
Favreau and felonious or Wars especially
Dave Filoni who's been with so much of
the extended mythology and the extended
mythology the fans have very much
embraced I feel like he could be the
fulcrum to a middle ground of Star Wars
that gives you all the Star Wars stuff
that you love and also pushes forward
into new territory sure that's the exact
circumstance I want so there's comments
here being asked about Morbius yeah so I
I don't know if you guys saw our trailer
reaction for my Mosu mean you did but
he's a star attraction for Morbius and I
did say and like in the big we make fun
of it at the beginning when I'm talking
about the film's the director has done
which were not well received and then
the writer films were definitely not
received in general of being a cobweb
movie I did get really excited when I
did see the vulture like that was very
surprising and genuine it's like of
course you know there's spider-man
tie-ins but to see that confirmation was
pretty cool even though there's people
coming out saying I've heard the thing
of people saying like but we don't know
for sure if it's vulture it could just
be an easter egg of Michael cameo just
being there and I'm like well why would
they just show Michael Keaton there then
why would he just why give that away in
the trail that way I think that would
piss people off if they go to the movie
and you're like he's not [ __ ] both
true like I feel like you Michael I
think they were just confuse your
audience it is even more yeah and
especially after you brought back JK
Simmons which like is a smaller like
more films but is a smaller role than
vulture was in spider-man homecoming
like at that point I did feel like it
would yeah be funky to just recast it
with some Rando but see like the movie
in and of it's like the spider-man
tie-ins playing into that side of
audiences and myself included yeah it
worked on me it really did in terms of
the marketing really worked on me well
in the in the Peter Parker led the
spider-man murder Amy yeah yeah yeah
that really worked for me but the the
film itself I did say it though in the
review part of the video which I know
not everyone sticks around for I did say
it there that I still can't tell what
exactly is unique about this one what
makes this one truly special I like what
could make it not not like I need to
know what the whole movie is but what
could make this one special goes right
now it seems very derivative of a lot of
things and I'm not sure what its actual
flavor that they're offering will make
it actually really I'm still skeptical
about it and I feel like trailers got to
be honest with what they're
communicating with the tone will be
venom like we we got really sold on
venom when we finally like remember we
heard the Eminem song yeah if you guys
remember the experience of watching the
venom trailers a lot of people were
really let down by the teaser and that's
an actual teaser trailer for most users
editor like full trailers now that was
an actual teaser trailer you don't see
venom in there and then in the official
trailer you see the venom moment where
he morphs into him and it was awesome
and we all got sold on the movie in the
movie did great and I personally really
loved the movie I didn't love it I
really liked it it's very enjoyable
despite many flaws but totally it's not
what those trailers are and I kind of
get a similar sort of a similar vibe
with this at them like there's
so that there's tonal elements to this
trailer that are not present here so
some stuff can look kind of cheesy
because of how serious it's going for I
hope it's good though you know I Oh even
for movies that I feel like we're gonna
be bad I don't I'm always more excited
to come out of a movie
and go I thought this was gonna suck and
it ended up being great now that I'm
saying that about Morbius
but I'd be more thrilled for it to be
good than to be like who told you cause
I rather be excited that it's good after
watching it yeah when I weirdly I'm
probably in the minority but I like the
idea of if they successfully if this is
the six new successful Sony spider-verse
I would love the idea of them sharing
back and forth with Marvel and having
like short Tom Holland crosses over here
and then he goes back over there and
like because of the multiverse stuff
that they're playing with I just feel
like that the doors are wide or open for
that than ever and if Sony can prove
themselves consistent I think that could
be really fun just to broaden out the
flavors and stuff yeah I did hear that
uh correct me there's a lot of movie
news has come out Watchmen we'll get to
it
double-oh-seven I did hear about Kraven
the hunter being in spider-man 3 is the
possible main villain which is
interesting to me because they that was
one of the developments for one other
like darker you know solo movies of the
Sony spider-man films the ones about the
villains and and did have him here it
seems like Marvel and Sony have worked
out some kind of special completely
different sort of deal especially with
the Fathy see spider-man the Morbius
trailer you see Bulger there there's
gotta be some special deal that's been
worked out but I don't know let's wait
to hear a little bit more when an actual
statement comes out Watchmen season 2
not happening that was my favorite show
last year I'm actually ok with that I I
think I think if the creator of that
series feels like he's got nothing more
to give perfect don't do it don't do any
more did it like I know it's a bummer
like don't get me wrong there's that
other side of me that's bummed about
that but hey if he if he truly feels
like he he put everything into this one
see
it's then I'm like cool then retitle it
Watchmen the miniseries as opposed to
Watchmen the show season 1 yeah well
yeah whose decision was it HBO not renew
it or did it is HBO saying that because
they Melinda law doesn't want to do it
uh-huh yeah that's our you know respect
because you could easily come back
probably so yeah mad respect have not
watched Forrest Gump yet no have not
when will you watch for actually over
Christmas break I was like this is the
time I'm gonna watch Forrest Gump and
Shawshank Redemption yeah never did it
oh how could you
hey Jane we just we just did you try not
to guys participate in the try not to
get hungry challenge yeah go in the gene
Jeter Channel and gene Jeter's Popeyes
that was something did you see did you
guys see the photo John can you pull it
up yes the photo of George Lowe locust
George Lucas George Lucas on Bojack
holding a baby Yoda I have not at was
seen this Obi Obi Wan wasn't Lucasfilm
just canceled the op1 series act is that
true someone just asked what we thought
of the Obi Wan uh-oh I don't know now no
no in just a second is that that can't
be true did they people were so excited
about that Ewan McGregor was like
finally I can talk about this mm-hmm oh
my god people asking for the longest
time look look at all these monitors
look at all these modern there we go
oh there he is with baby OS haven't seen
it look at that
mm very partial yeah there you go there
you go now we're small something that's
like he's holding it and the other side
is George Lucas doesn't look like he
gives two shits about it's a very blurry
photograph you're ready for Collider
videos to do another deep fake video now
whoo
hey those are still kind of funny hey
somebody somebody is on your wavelength
here with the Tobey Maguire Tom Hall and
Andrew Garfield Spyder crossover John
can you look up obi-wan
series canceled yes I can we just have a
moment of silence obi-wan John typed in
kobe-wan series he wants the whole or
make sure people can hear me okay eight
minutes ago the rap has reported no the
store the Star Wars obi-wan Kenobi
Disney Plus series isn't canceled guys
don't just fall for these fake news yeah
listen to Trump everything is fake
everything's fake news make up your own
facts life is all relative you're locked
into your perspective and you never
won't be double-oh-seven
I wonder how easy it would be to start a
movie news Rupert there's got to be some
way to do it just I put some reddit post
out there yeah just what seems to be
right
reddit user Hey somebody leaked this
information of a friend of a guy who
works at the students gotta be something
like that right you gotta [ __ ] with
should start our we should start the
onion version of movie news but like not
the onion though the daily current the
one that is not clearly satire that
people post half the time ago can you
believe this and then everybody gets in
the comment and they're like it's fake
we should we should be that site all
right guys we're gonna do a speed round
of a couple of questions really quick
then we're in the call of the day thank
you to everyone who's been here this
this whole time double-oh-seven
controversy what's our take barbara
broccoli is a racist yeah yeah against
women yeah racist against women and men
yeah I don't I don't care yeah I'm like
it would be cool to see a female James
Bond I get it James Bond's a dude like
rape ever I agree I'm all flume yeah
give us a double o8 who's a woman I
agree with her I mean for all we know
what they're doing with leshawna Lynch
in in the next Bond movie that could be
a character that they might be sending
up to have a spinoff well yeah maybe
they could do a successful version of
what they tried to do with jinx hey yeah
exactly
Halle Berry I mean I feel like they
could probably pull it off and maybe
learn some lessons from the past and
maybe broaden out their you
exactly so I feel like they can make it
work but the idea of I mean hey I'm also
glad it was Barbara broccoli who said it
fact that it's a woman who said it makes
a much bigger difference to for this far
because yeah I mean to to do to just
change James Bond - it's like it's in
tech it's part of it is integral to the
character for him to be a man I think
you could be whatever race I like that
it's not an issue like he ki he be yeah
name a race he could be correct but the
most obscure race you can think of it's
so much of him being a man as a part of
the character you gotta do it he is been
James yeah so I mean at that point you
Jane bond for all I care but yeah it
would just change the fundamentals I
guess but again me personally I don't
mind people are asking about Doctor Who
we are considering starting doing
reactions at our patreon page so a
doctor who maybe in February or March
actually so if you want that to happen
let us know those questions about it
Timmy Nader songs I remember you buddy
yeah Adam when wants to do it didn't you
just start watching the Clone Wars yeah
yeah I actually just got a list of how
to the chronological order how to watch
it David Gandy send it over to us
hopefully won't be doing a spies in
disguise boys three spies in disguise
don't hear anyway guys thank you so much
to everyone who's been here you guys
have been great
thanks for catching us up on all this
movie news overall you're lovely
support bill donations etc thank you for
everyone who got contribute to the super
chat to really means a lot
well so yeah we're gonna get going now
but much love happy Friday be safe on
the weekend how do you join patreon you
go to patreon.com/scishow reactions to
many shows
reaction highlights gluta from most of
them Q&A is music vid reacts Terminator
song in manator way to cap us off buddy
really appreciate that
much love thank you I love that
stimulator saw such a great title
dude and that penny wise hat alright
guys we'll talk with you soon
keep a lookout for future uploads and
future live streams